[Music]
and welcome back to another highly
cautious episode of careful boys we have
with us david soh hello
and we have this alex acosta aka lyft
god aka
so the other uh the other day we had
jason cheney here and him and bart
talking kind of brought back some
memories of military school
uh because they ended up going the same
freaking military did you know that
randomly the fact that he went to
military school blows my mind he is the
biggest [ __ ] i've ever met in my life
he's the one that we saw uh his ass beat
you guys oh by the way too jason is a
really good friend of mine let's just
preface this real quick
jason is the man he's like i [ __ ]
love the guy he's great he's hilarious
where'd you where'd you guys see his get
his ass beat so there was this
convenience boxing thing right the show
was a mess it was during covet at the
heat of it
right it was crazy like first of all you
would see people who have boxed their
whole life box somebody who has never
thrown a punch ever yeah oh my god
that's [ __ ] crazy you won one match
with this guy [ __ ] what's that jamar
jamar neighbors right he could box our
neighbors can [ __ ] box buff as and he
fought this other committee who was like
a fat mexican dude
that has never thrown a punch that's
[ __ ] up and he wailed on him
jamar is a boxer he's a boss and he's a
comedian and he's yolked and he's from
compton he was hitting with those body
shots like we got was just like this
apparently he's been boxing since he was
a kid or some [ __ ] yeah like it's not
there's nothing
how was it allowed so i don't even know
why jamar even did it i was like this
you're not gonna have any fun doing this
at all no he had fun i bet oh yeah
and he said jason jason got beat up so
jason cheney right first of all jason's
actually buff as [ __ ] buff yeah i can't
picture him getting into a fight though
it's so nice dude but for no [ __ ]
reason right and so there was this guy
that was his white dude they used to be
friends and he got on jason saying that
jason stole some of his jokes which is
so funny because i saw that white guy
stand up and he's the worst comic ever
dude i was like if somebody stole their
your jokes they would have killed
themselves dude this guy is so bad and
so
doesn't jesus change you a bunch of
asian jokes yeah
that'd be so funny when i grew up in
taiwan
hey you stole my joke man he stole my
taiwan joke well that's what jason was
like dude like my shit's about my
culture like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about but either way so they do
this match right and the funny thing was
that that guy that he box got booed
because he was hitting jason after the
bell he was doing punching him in the
back of the head and he's like yeah like
his girl or somebody was yelling out
like racist [ __ ] the last the last straw
was like people were gonna [ __ ] this guy
up like because they were just telling
him to get the [ __ ] out because his girl
[ __ ] [ __ ] bagged fishy [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] like as the fight is
done right jason's exhausted she goes
send him back to the [ __ ] factory is
what she [ __ ] yelled that's kind of
clever and then everybody's like yo what
the [ __ ] and they all got the death eyes
and they had to leave because they're
getting [ __ ] up they left early that
was like the first fight of the night
you know the first place damn what is
wrong with crazy
why don't know
it's a but it's a comedy it's a comedy
boxing match the reason why he was i
guess
because of the bad blood of him saying
like he stole my jokes and [ __ ] i guess
in their eyes
they could like talk all this [ __ ] to
[ __ ] jakes and cheney
but they're all pieces of [ __ ] they all
look like [ __ ] scumbags like did he
get [ __ ] up really i felt like he just
got tired more tired but he didn't
really get [ __ ] up jason cheney could
have won the fight if he trained with us
yes 100 why did he train because he
trained with the the gym that they were
boxing at and we didn't know him at the
time and we met him at the fight and
we're like oh this guy's cool we're
we're rooting for you bud why the other
guy sucks ass well none of these guys
none of these guys could box most of the
most only two that could box for pat and
chris chris sosa and the jamar neighbors
yeah our neighbors yeah yeah that [ __ ]
you actually see chris sosa and pat box
on online on youtube they had the full
match first round was pretty good until
chris got tired yeah yeah and then
pastor a piece of him up dude his dad
was his dad was so funny because he was
on my podcast right and i was like so
how did you feel about your son you know
you know what happened in the match he
goes he should have trained
he got it his dad just kind of gave up
he was like well that is what it is
he got stopped he didn't look good he
looked like he gave him box too he's
so when jason was here and he was
talking about military school did that
bring back something that you like
hadn't thought about forever yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy because um so one
i think
most people don't ever go to boarding
school yeah right it's just the crazy
thought where like if you're a kid or
whatever and you get sent away and
you're living without your parents and
then so um when i went to this military
school it was such a unique place
because it's either
literally the worst kids on the planet
it's it's it's kids that you got kicked
out of all these other schools already
and the parents don't want to deal with
them so they send them there so bart
me
or
the richest kids you've ever met in your
life like kids of politicians
celebrities like ceos of like major
companies
um or
uh when it was rich kids and then jason
cheney and the geekiest kids in the
world yeah
so kids were like the parachute kids
where like from other other places they
go oh i'm gonna cut the place you know
and they said they send the kids there
so it was like a crazy
like melting pot of those three and then
so it sounds like a public school in
california except you live there got it
that is very different and that's [ __ ]
and that's the crazy that's the part
that makes it crazy because like let's
say you can't leave yeah let's see me
and nick got into some [ __ ] and we scrap
like at the basketball court yeah i know
where he's sleeping at night
he knows where i'm sleeping at night i'm
gonna jizz on his pillow i know i know
his like
i know his boys
don't stay in his dorms they stay in
that hall they stay in that hall they
stay in that hall he knows where my boys
stay so that's why like it's such a
crazy like environment where it feels
like jail so it threw me off he actually
went to that where he [ __ ] went to
that squad i was like what's up you're
like dude you're the guy that i used to
steal lunch money from
that's why i wanted to know like what
years he went there but he didn't
remember he didn't remember they didn't
overlap yeah jason jenny doesn't
remember a lot of things dude
apple's always aloof i bet you when he
came on the show he didn't know he was
here yeah half of the time he was like
oh
i you know
how many no
and it was so funny
just just that was so funny he always
looks like he's missing a chromosome
somewhere dude
he's always looking for it he's so
[ __ ] funny dude he's probably to me
like no joke i'm telling this all the
time but he's the funniest asian comedy
to me in the in the states bro he's
gonna be huge i think he's way funnier
than ronnie chang funnier than joe coy
all these top dog people i think he his
material is ten times better than theirs
he is pretty funny though dude he's
really [ __ ] fun the reason why i i
like his material a lot is that he
doesn't shy away from his asian-ness but
he doesn't um
[ __ ] uh what's it called make a joke
out of our culture it's inside jokes
that asian people know but other people
can laugh at it too which is very very
very approachable yeah and jason can do
that really really [ __ ] well
something that i haven't seen ever most
people kind of stick to their crowds
they do like these little hacky asian
jokes because they know that white
people will laugh at it
he still plays to his culture but
everybody can laugh at it which is so
hard to [ __ ] do i legit think that he
is the best asian comic in the states
damn the best huh
from david too that means a lot yeah i
david don't like anybody yeah
i hate you dude
no david i don't even like shane cheese
i didn't like the movie the guy i hate
even more
the guy's cool he's fantastic he's great
dude he's cute
so yeah i was trying to i was i was
trying to get the years
because like i wanted to hear his
experience
because it's like it literally felt like
jail where all the races also kicked it
together
you know what i mean because it's like
the asians on one side the white ones
remember like you take off your shirt
you show the swastika just let people
know where you're at no on the on the
real confusing it's like [ __ ] like that
where i first so when i first got there
uh i went there um my junior year and
then they have like a new student
orientation right so a new student
orientation you could already tell like
everyone
they're trying to act hard and peacock
already they're like oh are you from oh
i'm from oakland where you from or
whatever right and then so slowly the
people's like where their hoods started
coming out into the beach yeah honey the
beach so they have like [ __ ] neo-nazi
dudes there and [ __ ] like that and you
start hearing about where people are
from and people want to act hard and
they start like like uh try to like get
a pecking order in place so it's crazy
and there's nothing where you can like
i'ma leave i'm gonna call my mom there
is none of that you know hey did you
ever see people like break down and cry
because that's a really difficult
situation for people i have it
that's me you can't see
[Laughter]
it's called a mirror dude
i know i couldn't see my eyes were full
of tears
man there's like dude honestly
when i went to that school i didn't even
think it was possible but i probably got
into a fight
at least once a day or maybe twice a day
what because it's so like um
it's so [ __ ] like i gotta assert my
dominance oh what about him and then the
races come so and people know where you
live right so they're like oh that food
like you know especially like back in
our high school days people just bump
into each other in the hallway and they
want to fight already so imagine you
have that and you you add like steroids
to it because it's full of men yeah so
now you're like oh [ __ ] hey i saw john
in this room by himself so you just
grabbed six dudes and then you just bum
rush the room and start beating the [ __ ]
out of them so it was like fights like
that all the [ __ ] time dude
the 90s sucked yeah so one of the times
that i noticed was uh so my roommate was
like this skinny like white boy that was
just super chill the chillest dude in
the world his last name was whistler and
i used to used to sit next to me and i
used to just pet his hair because it was
literally like the softest hair i ever
felt my whole life it felt like a dog a
certain that dominance i see no i wasn't
he was just super chill no i wasn't he's
like hey bart you want to pet my head
this is before after he sucked your dick
dude he's like he was my dog you made
him here he was sucking his dick and he
was dumb
these white dudes came in because they
were like part of like some sort of like
honey the beast like surf gang or some
[ __ ] and he wasn't kicking it with them
so they were wondering why like what was
what was wrong with us and you were
petting his [ __ ] head the whole time
he's like hey guys
what's going on
so i was just laying like in my in my
bed so it's like a bunk bed in like a
little space like this and i'm just
chilling
all of a sudden like five dudes come in
and that feeling is nuts yeah you know
because like you just know they're not
they're the anxiety as you're talking
about there to be like friends right
there's no and there's like
the it's like dorm rooms where it's not
like if someone sounds alarm like oh
fire or help me that the the adult
chaperones or whatever would be able to
find and locate your room immediately
you know it's going to take some [ __ ]
time they have to like hear and listen
oh [ __ ] it's room b 20 or whatever right
so i'm sitting there i'm in the in the
bottom bunk and i feel uh i feel the
five dudes come in and they talk to him
already and i'm like oh what's going on
here and then they're like oh we're not
here for you but like your butthole is
already tense yeah you're like okay this
is not a fun time and then they start
talking to him and they start pushing
him around and then that's when i got
pissed because uh he was just like the
nicest dude ever so i had a um you know
the padlock on the foot locker oh my god
so i took my hand i saw one dude in the
face and i grabbed the other dude and i
threw him out the window and then the
other three dudes acted like normal
white dudes and they ran away
out the window he knows
that [ __ ] like a
normal dude and it's like you're [ __ ]
15 years old 16 years old and then later
it's not like oh you feel like heroic or
whatever because you're like oh [ __ ] you
okay whistler
you okay
no one's gonna [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
you my [ __ ] whistler is that name his
real dave his name is jeremy
starts giving him food my name's not
whistler it's whistler yeah it's crazy
and then so later you're always you're
always stuck with your boys you don't
know what's gonna [ __ ] what floor
were you on that you threw a guy out the
window oh ours so i lived in
a good question
i lived in one of the cottages so it's
on the it's on the uh
the ground floor i like how you jazzy
jeff this guy dude
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
i wonder if it's the if it's the same
like with jason cheney's generation
because like everything got soft like
even our high school we went to keppel
that was like
it was like 11 different asian gangs at
once and there was a fight like every
[ __ ] week hey once cell phone cameras
and social media came on though that
[ __ ] got really dangerous for anybody
trying to start i feel like it's not
even that it got soft it got normal like
that's how normal people should be
that's true that's not normal yeah like
all right all this stuff's [ __ ] suck
when you look back at it and you start
talking about these stories like we'll
reminisce right and then you'll tell
tell these stories to other people when
you go to college they're like where the
[ __ ] did you live yeah but when we grew
up um that wasn't that it got that
[ __ ] up yeah cause like let's say our
brother like i don't know
guys are in their late 40s now they were
the beginning of that
yeah and then if like guys are that are
in the 50s and above it's not the same
that's why i have all these memories
that are like pushed down and then when
jason cheney said he went to army navy
academy and we started talking i started
getting all these like oh sure i was
like what what the [ __ ] dude we were we
were [ __ ] uh eating sushi just the
other day and then our other buddy
talked about he saw somebody and it
sparked the memory when i was seven
years old i was in front of my parents
uh store and i saw a cop shoot somebody
in front of our store when i was seven
years old
and like i forgot about that [ __ ]
memory but it was during the time that
we were um expanding our store over and
so we had to do work at night and you
know i'm helping my parents and i was i
was hanging outside and i don't remember
the exact specifics but i do remember
these cops unloading on this guy and i
could remember the sound of him trying
to breathe because like like damn
like i remember that noise and i was
like i [ __ ] forgot about that [ __ ]
and i was telling um
my my memorial about it and then she was
like that's not normal
and i'm like oh [ __ ] that isn't did your
parents know it depends on where you
live it's normal i mean well that
neighborhood that i grew up in was
really [ __ ] bad at the time like it
was [ __ ] terrible so like when you
kind of compartmentalize it if it's
every day and it didn't happen every day
but bad things like that did happen a
lot you don't really think about it it's
just like oh [ __ ] i remember the cops
were talking to me asking me what
happened and i just kept saying i don't
know i don't know because i'm a nervous
little kid i'm like i don't know i don't
know i don't know and then my dad had to
come out and he had to tell them like he
didn't see anything he was just out
there he ain't no snitch
and then the neighborhood came out
they're like what's up my n-word
and they dapped me the [ __ ] up but all
these things when we were younger like
times have changed so much now like my
parents were telling me now at the store
there's security guards there it's super
cleaned up nobody's shooting dice
outside there's no block bad guys shoot
themselves
yeah but it's just a different time like
like when we reminisce about like we you
know we say things like oh people are i
think it's just normal this is how
people should be but you know what's
weird though is like
people are still shooting each other up
the crime's still happening people are
going in like you know grabbing [ __ ] now
and like running away with it or they're
holding up people in broad daylight
like it's still happening but it's just
like the violence that we grew up with
with the fistfights and everything every
day it's just a different vibe with high
schoolers i mean i noticed distinctly
that asians don't [ __ ] with each other
as bad as they used to
because i remember when i was in high
school and i just went somewhere where i
didn't know people
everybody was waiting to [ __ ] with you
for some weird yeah yeah yeah yeah hey i
remember asians used to be way more
segregated too for sure like we're like
fullerton cerritos for no reason like
you could go to cerritos mall and just a
different group of asians that don't
know you the first instinct is to assert
some kind of like just to get punked
yeah what type of video are you huh yeah
it was like weird but that's not a thing
now right like the younger generation is
going no because i remember like it was
really weird seeing like a korean dude
hang outside of his korean group like
koreans just stuck with koreans chinese
with chinese vietnamese would mix with
chinese whatever filipinos were on their
own and then like you know you don't
really see like now the diversity of so
many people like not only hanging out
with different friends
of different races but dating to like
this ain't even the 1950s this is just
like early 2000s and then even in high
school too like
you kind of saw like a little bit of
separation like you'll never see
mexicans and asians hang out you know
like it was
it was it was kind of weird it was like
these weird like race wars so i remember
like around your guys's year it was
pretty bad and then my ear started to
taper down a little bit that's when
dancing became a little cooler like
everybody wanted to join the dance team
in high school versus like not going to
school like having school pride wasn't a
[ __ ] thing and then like even my year
was like kind of bad but the years
before that i remember they would have
like a school pride [ __ ] our year didn't
give a [ __ ] like i remember when we
graduated it was our last school
assembly and they're like this is your
last school assembly and our whole class
was like shut the [ __ ] up
because nobody cared you know school
spirit yeah no school spirit whatever
but the year before us had a lot of
school spirit they actually cared about
like academics they cared about these
things that were like just not
traditionally cool to us nerds did those
guys ever come back and [ __ ] with you
again the white dudes no those ones
didn't um so like
what's crazy is
at that school
it's
it kind of sucks but in the early on and
kind of like jail you really have to
kind of like make a name for yourself
so like um i remember in the orientation
there was a korean dude of course and
then he was like maybe like i don't know
david's eyes it was like he was bigger
and then and he was he kept he was like
kept talking [ __ ] to me
i forgot what away
he kept talking [ __ ] to me over and over
again he's telling me how he's from like
northridge or whatever i don't know
that's funny or whatever right i'm like
man this is like in my mind i'm like
this is a [ __ ] i don't know [ __ ]
intense school got kicked out of i just
want to like keep my head down and just
do my thing and i know it's expensive
i'm just trying to like get out of here
but also i can feel the energy is crazy
like everyone's just like i'm gonna [ __ ]
this fool up i'm down to get into
another fight i don't give a [ __ ]
and then so it ended up being where um
he's like yeah i'll take you whatever
and i'll you know what i was like
i found out that there was a wrestling
room next to um the weight room and i'm
like i'm like whatever questions you got
i was like we'll we'll handle it later
if you want he goes all right so later
on i was working out
and then uh he came in he was working
out too and i was like oh you want to
find out and then he's like all right
so what's your favorite color
bar's getting ready to fight he goes
i love magenta
i made some best friend bracelets and i
just wanted to know
whatever
he has like the puka shell necklace for
you
and uh so i wrestled a little bit at
this point and you know a little bit of
wrestling goes a long way yeah so uh we
we touch knuckles he throws a jab i
shoot and i dump his ass [ __ ] hard
and i go need a belly and i'm like you
want anything else he goes nah i'm good
what's crazy is so this is the guy that
hit us up on instagram oh that crazy
[ __ ] craziest this guy now i
think i don't know i earned his
allegiance or some [ __ ] from that point
on he always called me young
and then uh as our group started growing
he would do all kinds of like [ __ ] for
me and i'm like hail that dude borrow my
hair clippers get it back from me and
you like whatever you want young and
you'll go and you go hey he doesn't have
it and i'm like well you better figure
out a way and he'll just jump that full
for me that's tight like yeah it was
crazy it's a little crazy dude
so you're saying you had like a pet
whistler
you had a giant korean bulldog in your
dick and then you had yeah an enforcer
yeah this is willie wilson this is
tenjong david
you know like
korean like hyung culture hierarchy is
really really big so what is it it's big
man so like we so if you have somebody
who's older you call them young sp even
especially if you respect them like in
you never ever address somebody that you
especially if you respect them if
they're older by their name that's
[ __ ] disrespectful as [ __ ] in korean
gang culture specifically that's even
more
so like korean gangs like i don't know
how it is now but this is me just
regelling stories from other people
right it's to the point like we would
always have like young gunners right so
these young people were [ __ ] nuts
if you tell them to shoot they shoot
that's it yeah [ __ ] especially in l.a
i would hear stories about all these
like korean dudes in l.a having like
these young kids they would just come up
and they would be like they would groom
them since they're like 12 13 14 years
old and they would use them as a younger
and they would just make them these
psychopaths and the reason why is
because the young kids they can go to
juvie and they'll come out they have a
clean record it doesn't [ __ ] matter
so they would make these young kids do
everything and they were so [ __ ]
loyal so even like back in the day if
you guys go to k-town there's a very
well-known uh bar out there that
everybody goes to
blue the [ __ ] blue [ __ ] [ __ ] would
go down there all the [ __ ] time i
remember one time when i was at blue
i was about to go to blue we're walking
in because we're about to meet some
other friends and then there's this
young dude that walks up to me he goes
hey what's up you david so korean kid
shaved head i'm like yeah what's up he
goes hey i'm a big fan but don't go in
there some shit's about to pop oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] somebody gets stabbed there dude
and i was like you know what i'm not
going to blue anymore that's such a sick
fan what a g bro good gosh what are you
stabbing at night well he's young he's
young
he's like i want to have a photo but
this is a crime scene so let's do it
later hey man big fat hey hyung don't go
inside something's about to pop off
oh [ __ ] this guy was super so like you
know as the group started um
hanging out together like all the asians
with whatever all the black kids or
whatever um like there's they they they
kick it together and of course there's
people that aren't about the violence
right there's people that went there
that actually do well in school like
probably like jason cheney whatever and
they'll get punked by the other races so
they'll end up feeding that information
up like hey man like this guy just stole
my wallet or whatever and then they're
looking for protection because that's
the only way you could really survive in
the school which is probably why jason
cheney got bullied like crazy he
probably didn't click up with anybody
and this dude i would just be like yo
this dude just got his wallet stolen get
it back from him and then he would just
go and i would just see him go straight
like they could be playing a game of
basketball mid game just going to start
bombing the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
i don't ever want to go back to high
school ever keep it real will you like
top dog you talking about a guy there's
a guy named wang i'm not gonna say his
first name but he was like bill
phillips will write love stories
[Music]
[Music]
you